Oh
I started blogging in September of 2004
which is a long time ago especially in
the internet at the time I was working
for a lot of the gay publications and i
started the site as a hobby thinking
that nobody would read it maybe my
friends but not even sure they would and
it kind of turned into this thing where
now I get over 10 million readers a day
and I never could have imagined any of
it
what's interesting about now as opposed
to back in 2004 when I started my
website is that these days a lot of
people will start blogs like mine with
the sole intention of trying to make
money from it and doing it for a living
but when I started blogging back in
September 2004 I didn't know or think or
even imagine that you could make a
living just being a Dossett blogger but
it took a long time before I started to
make enough money to be able to just do
that full time it took close to a year
and a half
I think that when i first started my
site really stood apart from other blogs
on the internet because before me most
blogs were very first person they were
online Diaries or journals today I woke
up and I had breakfast and I got into a
fight with a coworker at work and I went
on a hot date but that never really
interested in me I want to talk about
celebrities because a lot of them are
crazy so the fact that I was one of the
first definitely helped me gave me an
advantage and the biggest success secret
that I have is just hard work I work
insanely hard on my website and I still
do I haven't gotten complacent I haven't
gotten lazy and I still love it as much
as I did when I first started